yes it is very broken right now the main
break i believe is simply the influence
of money it just astonishes me that when
representative from the National Science
Foundation comes down to visit us we
cannot buy her dinner we cannot buy her
cup of coffee because that might
influence her decision that's great but
if i want to give thousands and
thousands of dollars to a congressman no
problem yeah i can give as much as i
want obviously there are limits of
course if i bundle things together
basically nine thousand dollars per
couple we can give now so from what I
hear from politicians and from people
who work with politicians they have to
spend most most of their effort really
is from fundraising and pleasing donors
that means it's broken so I think we
desperately need to have massive public
financing reduce the cap on donations to
something like two hundred dollars per
person there is no reason a person
should get access to a politician
because they give them money that's
broken no people who are on the extremes
pretty much can't be changed there's not
much hope for them the trick is to run a
society in which they have as little
voice as possible and right now because
of the free market that we have in
entertainment and television and I'm not
advocating censorship but because the
extremes are more entertaining we do
have we have fox news on the one hand
and the religious right also on that
side and we have people like well I love
without any names we have the the angry
new atheists who write these slash and
burn books if you read those books while
they talk as though they're scientists
they are so focused on using reasoning
to reach the conclusion they are
committed to this I do not think is
helpful the very nature of our of our
tribalism is such that we went attacked
we rally the troops and we're really
good intergroup competition so the trick
for the future is to find ways to
recreate what used to be called the
Vital center a place where people find
the joy of learning from both sides
people run the extremes that's
psychologically not possible for them
I'm both optimistic and pessimistic I'm
pessimistic and that I think some
terrible things are almost certain to
happen I think that we will see a
nuclear bomb go off in a city somewhere
in the world in the next 20 years and
then how we react to that could be
terrible as well so I think that it's
going to be something of a roller
coaster and in part that's because of
the diffusion of technology and the ease
with which anyone with a grudge can now
be very powerful so I'm pessimistic in
terms of there being likely to be some
terrible terrible things that will
happen I am optimistic that the effects
of the 1960s will soon wear off that is
the moral radicalization of the left and
right i think is coming to an end and i
am hopeful that we will begin to
understand each other better to respect
each other more and to create a society
that draws on the wisdom of both sides
I'm also humbled by the fact that is
almost impossible to predict anything so
whether I'm optimistic or pessimistic
how kind of console myself with the
thought that things will change and we
cannot predict what will happen I can
reproduce